-John Legend!
We love it when
you come to the show.
We love it when you're here.
You look sharp as always.
-I love being here.
-Thanks for being here.
-I like the beard.
-You do?
-Yes.
-I'm trying to be you.
[ Laughter ]
It's taking some time.
It's a little patchy there.
-Welcome to the club.
-Thank you, my friend.
I appreciate that.
-Yes.
-We got a lot to talk about.
-Yeah.
-"Legend." Your new album.
-It's out.
-It's out finally.
-It feels good to have it out
in the world.
-Talk about "The Voice."
You know what I wanted
to talk about?
Because a lot of people ask
because we always --
You've been on the show
a bunch of times.
They go,
"You guys got good chemistry."
-We go way back.
We were actually in a group
together.
-Yeah.
-In the '90s, an R&B group.
-Yeah. Yeah.
It was a long time ago.
And we were called
Color Me Interestedd.
-Yeah, that's right.
With two D's on the end.
-With two D's.
-Interested-d.
-Interested-d 'cause we're
extremely interesting.
-Interestedd.
Color Me Interestedd.
-Yes, and we were
a very, very sexy R&B group.
-At the time,
some people said too sexy.
-Yeah.
We get accused of being
too sexy a lot.
-Yeah, we do.
-But looking back, I maybe think
the lyrics weren't
as sexy as we thought.
-Well, you're not going to
believe this,
but I found a clip of...
[ Laughter ]
...our first performance.
-Uh-oh.
-Yeah.
-I'm not --
-Here's John Legend and I in our
old group, Color Me Interested.
♪♪
♪ Mm, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Wow, wow, wow ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Girl, come on over here
and sit next to me ♪
♪ When we're together,
it is pure ecstasy ♪
-♪ Put some tantalizing thing
on the TV ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ It's a little show ♪
♪ I like to call "Jeopardy!" ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I always get
all the questions right ♪
-♪ It's the same VHS
that I watch every night ♪
-♪ Or "Wheel of Fortune"
or whatever you like ♪
-♪ Call me Pat Sajak,
and you're my Vanna White ♪
-♪ And that's what keeps me
interested, girl ♪
♪ And that's what keeps me
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-You know, looking back --
looking back --
[ Laughter ]
It's good to look back,
isn't it?
-Yes.
-We were definitely sexy,
I think.
-Yeah, I mean,
but the reviews were
that we weren't sexy enough.
-That's true.
They weren't really going there
with our lyrics or stuff
like that.
So we had to up our sexy game
a little bit.
-You don't have a clip of that,
right?
-You talking about the second
song we released?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Roll the clip.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Ooh, yeah, yeah, wow, yeah ♪
-♪ Say what ♪
-♪ What? ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Arm around my girl
and we are getting so close ♪
-Ooh!
-♪ I lean in slowly ♪
♪ Yeah, you know how this goes ♪
-♪ Yeah, lips to her ear
and I whisper real low ♪
♪ Is there spinach in my teeth,
girl? ♪
♪ Please tell me no ♪
-♪ Get close to me,
what food do you see? ♪
-♪ Is that a piece of lettuce
or a sesame seed? ♪
-♪ Girl, come on and get close
to me ♪
-♪ I said open up your eyes
and look at my teeth ♪
-♪ And that's what keeps me
interested, girl ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. We're back.
-And here again.
-Nice clip, nice clip.
-It made me chilly.
It made me chilly. It's so good.
-Yeah, yes.
-But yet again, I think
it missed the sexy mark,
don't you agree?
-Well, thankfully our label,
Nasty Little Freak Records.
-That's correct. Shout-out.
-They gave us one last shot.
-They gave us all the budget
in the world to do -- they said,
"One more shot for you guys."
-And this time,
the sexy was definitely --
-We got to keep people
interested-d.
-Interested-d-d-d.
-We have to keep people
interested-d.
-We had to unleash
the full sexy,
so we might as well watch
that one too.
-Let's see it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Oh, wow, wow ♪
-♪ Wow ♪
-♪ Ooh, yeah, no, no ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, ah, yeah ♪
-♪ Ah, no ♪
♪ Hands down her arms, her legs,
and then down her back ♪
-♪ Ooh, ah ♪
♪ I check every nook,
every curve, every crack ♪
-Ooh!
♪ There's no one else with
your heart and your soul ♪
-♪ So please, girl, be checking
for suspicious moles ♪
-♪ Girl, I want to feel you
up and down ♪
-♪ I check the color and the
shape, make sure they're round ♪
-♪ That mole on your neck
is so damn fine ♪
-♪ But I want to make sure
that it's benign ♪
-♪ And that's what keeps me
interested, girl ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now look at us now.
-We've come a long way.
-My thanks to John Legend.
We're talking to John about
his new album, "Legend"!
After the break. Stick around.
-♪ Ain't you interested, girl ♪
♪ That's what keeps me
interested, girl ♪
-♪ Wow, wow ♪